[Music]
i really like working with adam um you
know it's uh you know he has a very
clear vision what he wants really
irrelevant to me i don't know who
who decides that just put that stuff out
there kind of pisses me off a little bit
because
we have discussions on everything and
that's that's our job we have to do we
have to work through so much stuff
that's what we got to do
and
you know that's all we've done since
we've been here since we started we just
constantly were in communication
whether he's coming out of my office or
i'm going to his office
that's all we're trying to do is just
trying to make sure that we're on the
same page all the time
[Music]
well they were on the same page not for
very long and i think the fact that
there was that constant communication
chris that led to
the and look i don't know that it was a
coup i don't know that it was a power
play deliberately it's just possible the
circumstance of taking mike mckagne and
adam gase and mashing them together for
four months resulted in
natural inherent dysfunction that caused
christopher johnson ceo the team to look
at and say this can't continue these are
two dramatically different personalities
and we're going to be better off with
someone who is better suited to dealing
with adam gase because gase is clearly
the coach and gase is the guy who is
decisive and motivated and driven and
reportedly the knock on mckagman is he
was a little too wishy-washy a little
too indecisive and i just think that
that is a bad combination and
christopher johnson
eventually agreed yeah well i you know i
don't look at it as a coup d'etat or
anything like that i mean at least from
my standpoint i look at it more like
okay here's a guy adam gates that got
hired i got to imagine that mike
mccagnum is already on the radar of
christopher johnson and maybe some other
people higher up in the organization as
far as not being totally happy or
satisfied with the job they had done to
this point i mean they had to be to a
degree or they're crazy as well i mean
we can't sit here and go oh mc cagnan's
been awesome and this has been amazing
so far there's been some good moments
but as the jet fans up here in the new
york area know you know yeah the good
moments have been you know okay traded
up and was fortunate that sam darnold
fell to them right that was a great
moment leonard williams fell exactly to
them jamal adams we just saw this year
quincy williams fell to them so those
are positive moments but i don't think
you know myself or any of the jets fans
really look at that and go oh what great
moves by mike mcagon other than maybe
sam darnold so you know there's been
issues with team building not being able
to get a pass rusher really never being
able to draft a receiver with any talent
uh you know whether it's devin smith out
of ohio state who didn't work out i mean
their best receiver they've signed or
got is robbie anderson who was an
undrafted free agency but then you go
into the christian hackenberg moments
christian hackenberg in the second round
i mean that is one of the worst picks in
modern history i mean he really is i
don't know if he should have been
drafted let alone if he was it should
have been the sixth or seventh down
trading to get bryce petty i mean i can
go on and on down the list of very
suspect moves there so so where i can
understand where this move or why this
move was made and maybe adam gase just
gave the push over the edge when things
didn't go well to bring up some more
issues that he didn't like maybe with
ownership and that's maybe what got it
all done at the end of the day i just
don't like the idea that if you had
misgivings about mike mckagan why not
fire him when you fire todd bowles the
head coach and then you start from
scratch then because now
there is going to be a potential element
of a forced marriage where adam gase is
there as the head coach you bring in a
gm the typical model is if the gm is
going to have final say over the
football operation the gm
eventually wants to hire his own coach
and you're gonna have to find a guy that
the gm is comfortable with and a guy
that the coach is comfortable with so
it's basically going to be an adam gase
hire that's the easiest way to fill this
job gase now is the interim gm and even
if he doesn't have final say moving
forward and i think there's a chance he
will have final say or if not in writing
as a practical matter he's going to be
calling the shots i think this is going
to be a gay sky first name that came up
joe douglas the eagles director of
player personnel a gays guy it's gonna
be a gays guy and when christopher
johnson the owner of the team says he's
looking for a great strategic thinker a
great communicator great collaborator
great leader great manager whatever i
think it's going to be gays regardless
of whether or not
someone else holds the title of gm and i
assume someone will hold that title of
gm there won't be a director of player
personnel or anything like that
whoever the gm is i think the end result
here is gase runs the football operation
well i think you'll have a big say in it
i'm not gonna i don't know i don't i
don't know if i definitely agree with
you that he'll just have flat out final
say over it you know either way hey
there's nothing wrong with them getting
a guy in there that adam gase likes or
has a relationship with or you know sees
eye to eye on football values and how to
build a team so if joe douglas is a guy
you know from philadelphia who's been
around and i've heard a lot of good
things about from a lot of different
people around the nfl uh it makes sense
to want to want to hire a gm that you
know the head coach respects and has a
very good working football relationship
to go with anyways hey the other thing
here too is i've had a lot of my jet
friends and stuff go oh well i mean
they're going to give gase you know
power of the roster right now did they
see what happened down in miami you know
okay i'm sure adam gase made a few moves
in miami he didn't love but at the end
of the day man miami's got a lot of
things going on down there i know from a
lot of people and i've heard it from all
around you know that there's a lot of
cooks in the kitchen kitchen down there
in miami there's a lot of people
sticking their hand into football
decisions that shouldn't be doing it and
i think that there was things that were
kind of a mess down there and that
didn't exactly help adam gaze out either
but i think
there's a lot of cooks in the kitchen in
miami and and the master chef doesn't
live there i mean that is that is a stew
of dysfunction and it actually got
better when gase became the coach it was
untenable before gates became the head
coach and gase went to the playoffs his
first year that's right and he made some
tough moves with some guys that got
pushed out of town that he's because
he's trying to build a team sure that's
the sign on the wall at new england
we're not just college we're building a
football exactly right right yeah that's
what he tried to do in miami he did and
people gave him flack for ndamukong suh
and look here we are now two years out
and stews still that on a team and he's
looking for a new one because the team
didn't want him after miami so you know
you know yeah yeah okay but but jarvis
landry's kind of worked out for the
browns and mike pouncey kind of worked
out for the chargers so you're being
selective there and yeah you know jarvis
landry okay he worked out the brown's
way overpaid him you know that's the
other thing too you got to remember
there that's what adam gase didn't want
to do at the end of the day he didn't
want to pay jarvis landry 15 million
dollars a year for a guy who works in
the slot and catches a lot of short
passes and screens so i understand that
so that's where he drew the line there i
think it was actually a good football
decision they got some other receivers
in there last year they were extremely
talented you know some of them got hurt
like albert wilson but they showed that
they were able to make some things
happen in that dolphins offense too so
either way listen
this this i go back to this to being one
of the root problems of gm's i had
always heard that mike mccagnin was
about to be fired by the houston texans
but you know what happened and this is
the new thing in the nfl where the
owners are going to call people they
know well the owner of the jets they
called charlie casterly who's you know
been in the nfl media and out of the nfl
game for a little bit now but they call
him charlie gasserly's hey help us find
a new gm well charlie castle's friend is
mike mccagnan so of course mike mckagne
now gets in the running for running the
organization and now he is the gm for
the new york jets so i know there was
people and i'm sure christopher johnson
and the rest of the ownership probably
heard as time went on that mike mckagne
didn't necessarily have the greatest
reputation before he got there anyways
so i'm sure that made them scratch their
heads let alone with some of the draft
picks and moves they made in free agency
like overpaying le'veon bell this year
overpaying tremaine johnson last year
you know uh not being able to make the
anthony bar move happen you know the
ryan fitzpatrick giving him too much
money into year two after you knew it
was a one year magical run move on you
knew it wasn't going to work we know
what ryan fitzpatrick is at this point
happy like john elway oh he went to the
playoffs with tim tebow that was nice
but i don't think we're gonna go any
farther we gotta make a bold move and go
get a peyton manning so i think there's
a lot of things there that the jets fans
have this pent up frustration and i
understand why the move was made i i
i agree with most of what you said
though i don't blame mike mccartney for
anthony barr i blame the agent for yeah
the agent the agent should have realized
there was misgivings on the part of
anthony barr because there clearly were
and that's when the agent has to say
dude you understand
that telling me yes is the same thing as
putting your name on the contract
because if you if you go back on this we
all look bad and you have to be all in
before i tell them you're taking the
offer but
you know regardless of all of that i i
agree
and it continues to point to me
to a situation where they're going to
find a gm that gase wants and and for
the same reasons that you know a charlie
castle he recommends a mike mccagnin
adam gase is going to recommend a friend
right a former colleague someone that he
knows he'll be able to work with and
that person is going to be grateful to
gays he's going to be indebted to gays
and even if the new gm
has at the bottom of his contract you
have final say over the draft and the
53-man roster gates is going to be the
guy he'll have a lot of practical matter
tells the gm
how it's going to be
and and that's just the for we know gays
that's the force of his personality
right and you can't have a guy exactly
like gays in that job otherwise it'll
explode they'll find somebody that gates
will believe he can work with and that
gates will believe will do the things
that gays wants and you mentioned
le'veon bell yeah le'veon bell was
overpaid by the jets they could have
gotten him for less than what they paid
him right and i believe that adam gase
was banging that drum and they didn't
listen to him and that ends up becoming
one of the reasons why magma cagnet
isn't there because they did pay overpay
a guy who hasn't shown up for the off
season program that may have been the
final straw as far as christopher
johnson was concerned we gave all this
money to le'veon bell he's not here for
the off-season program maybe gase was
right we should have given him less yeah
i mean that certainly could have been
you know the final nail in the coffin
yes there was no market for le'veon bell
as i understand it and you know i've
talked to a lot of people about this
subject i mean literally le'veon bell's
agent was calling teams going hey you
can have le'veon bell for this much per
year and it was of course significantly
less than what the jets gave them per
year which is what 12 million dollars
you know that from everything i know
they created a market at the last second
when they realized there was no market
they called around teams you can have
them for eight nine million dollars a
year and teams were like whoa well we
didn't expect that hold on we'll call
you back and maybe maybe we can find
some way to finagle our situation and
get le'veon bell on the roster so that's
really what happened yeah the jets
didn't uh the jets overpaid certainly
you know but here's another thing that
i've heard a lot from up here you know
why would they let mccagnan spend all
this money in free agency okay i get
that but i would bet you there was a lot
of conversations with adam gase about
these players they signed in free agency
for the most part and i would think for
the most part adam geese gave a stamp of
approval on a lot of these guys to go
with it to why they were signed too so
it wasn't like it was just mike mccagnin
building a team without anybody talking
to him or anything like that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports